hello and welcome to part 2 of my SEO
tutorial before we get too much further
I will just say I want to alert you guys
to one of the better resources you could
check out and that's gonna be straight
from google.com it's
developers.google.com/live master slash
google for webmasters i will actually be
putting this link in the description and
i'll try to just put it in all the
videos in this series but if not that's
the link and there's there's a lot of
good information here as well as good
information on what you shouldn't do
especially so there's some some useful
stuff here alongside what I'm going to
be talking about so the first thing I
think we should talk about is kind of
one of the basics of what exactly Google
does to show results in a search so the
first thing you need to understand is
what Google's crobat is actually going
to do is it just kind of crawls around
the internet and it uses these
algorithms to decide on what exactly it
should crawl when to do it and how
frequently to even do it and so one
thing you can do immediately to
expediate this process and probably make
it a little bit better especially how
quickly is school going to look through
your website is going to be to submit a
sitemap to Google so what Google will
normally do is able to just crawl pages
and every time it finds a link it's just
gonna kind of like store that link and
remember it and then also it's going to
look for more content and look for the
content on that page and start storing
that content as well and do what's
called index that content so another
thing that Google makes clear is that
you can't really pay to be indexed in
any way the closest thing to that would
be advertising and so you can like pay
to have you know kind of like an
advertised link that's as good as it
gets and doing this doesn't help your
search results in any way and actually
if you can if you think about it one
thing one service that you can use from
the Google that can actually kind of
hurt your ranking is Adsense so if you
have like a bunch of ads on your web
page Google's going to
recognize that and actually kind of rank
you lower for doing that so keep that in
mind so pretty much at the indexing
stage or at least getting the crawl bots
to get to your website or get to your
content the only thing you can do to
kind of speed this up you don't have to
do this but the only thing you can
really do to speed this up is submit a
sitemap straight to Google you've got to
also do some backlinking but I assure
you it's a bad idea and unless of course
they're legit backlinks but mostly the
easiest thing to do is just submit a
sitemap to Google webmasters otherwise
Google will crawl it eventually store
the links and slowly make its way
through your website so this SEO
tutorial how do we submit a sitemap well
what you want to do go to google.com and
slash webmasters once you do that you
should find yourself on this page
basically and you'll want to sign in to
webmaster tools I've already done this
I'm here if you don't already have a
site in webmaster tools which you very
well might not it won't look like this
it'll be a different page and we'll be
like add a website something like that
and it'll basically take you to bait
this point here so let's say we wanted
to add another website you could put in
wlwt's index com you hit continue here
let's see if it'll take me through the
same yeah okay so what it'll do is just
in case anybody doesn't know HTTP colon
slash slash cent XCOM is different and
seen differently as HTTP colon slash
slash WWN Dexcom that's why I'm able to
do what I'm doing here anyway
so once you try to add a website the
next thing that's going to be like is
wouldn't even own this website and so
there's a couple of ways you can do it
one is Google Analytics so what it's
going to do is going to look for this
Google the Google Analytics tracking
code basically that you put in your
website if you don't have Google
Analytics you should have Google
Analytics so and we will go over that in
a future tutorial but right now we just
want to get through signing in and
putting your website on webmaster tools
so if you don't have Google
lytx there's a few other things that you
can do so you could go to alternative
methods and one thing you do is just
upload an HTML file to your website give
Google the link they're gonna confirm
that you indeed uploaded that HTML file
good thing you can do domain name
provider you could add a tag you can do
all kinds of stuff anyway
I would just you know I'm gonna just say
verify with Google Analytics so we'll
hit verify and it would be like oh yeah
you do have Google Analytics
congratulations continue oh and it has
to be tied to this account right so so
the reason it worked was because my my
account that I'm on is the admin of the
Google Analytics account so if that if
that's not matching up it won't work but
you can upload the HTML file or do like
a million different things to do it so
it's pretty easy so once you're here
you'll probably see something
identically to this over time this stuff
will start to get populated but some of
the things that you can do immediately
is what we were saying is add a sitemap
so interestingly enough I don't know if
I can do it from here or not oh I could
but anyway all over on the side you
would just normally it was closed like
this you hit crawl and then sitemap so
there's a couple of different ways you
can get there but anyway I've already
submitted a sitemap on the other version
of sent XCOM but on the WWV version i'll
have a sitemap so I shouldn't submit a
sitemap and so the question is what the
heck is a sitemap well this is a sitemap
a sitemap is an XML document that
contains basically just a bunch of links
now this one's a little bit different
it's a little more high-class but for
the most part it's really just like a
URL tree so to speak so and if you have
a lot of URLs you kind of want to split
them up into little separate one so this
one's got a home page but then you've
got all my posts and all my pages so for
example let's open up the post one and
so as you can see it's a bunch of URLs
of all the posts that I've made
apparently I made 132 and then as you'll
see over here as well you can see that
well you probably don't know what these
numbers mean let me scroll up this has
the number of images on this page
priority which
kind of corresponds to like how how much
or what kind of priority should Google
put on on crawling this page over
another page change frequency this kind
of alerts Google and also just shows
like how much how often is this being
changed and also there's a last change
there's another version that of a
sitemap that you can make which looks
like this right where it's just straight
up just links and you just make an XML
document that contains all of these
links but honestly this is not an XML
document by the way this is just an HTML
version of a bunch of links so anyway
that's what it would look like you can
make yours as basic as that I don't even
have that many links so it's not as
necessary to like separate them up in a
little content stuff like this just a
good idea for as you expand to do that
so keep that in mind but that that's
what a sitemap is now to submit the
sitemap you would just take that part of
the URL so we come back over to
webmaster tools add it and as you can
see there do you put the beginning of
our link in there so now we just put the
end of it now what you want to maybe do
immediately is just test the sitemap
make sure the actual sitemap worked you
can view the test results and you'll see
that it did work obviously if I
submitted that HTML version it would be
like once an HTML sitemap and it would
be angry at me so anyway we'll submit it
put it in fresh the page and what you'll
see is initially it'll say pending but
really this process once you submit it
it's very very fast that is how you
submit a sitemap into Google so one last
thing that we can do real quick is to
leave this and instead say submit your
content and then from here you can say
participate and so you can do something
like HTTP colon slash slash
ww sent Dexcom and run through this
sorry and oh my gosh I can't read these
caches man maybe this one plz issue
focus okay
so then there we were able to submit or
me anywhere else and then every now and
then you could submit like a new page or
something like that if it's not being
indexed but we'll get more into depth
into those things
there's definitely a lot to cover with
SEO so those are just some couple of
quick basic things that we can do for a
website as always thanks for watching
thank you for your support your
subscriptions and until next time